Luckily for everyone, I'm a
sports engineer and not an
England International.
But I'd love to measure exactly
what's going on when
our International footballer
takes a penalty under those
extreme tournament conditions.
Here in the biomechanics lab,
we can take accurate
measurements of movement.
The cameras and lights are on,
I'm wearing my black suit,
I've got passive markers
all over me.
I can sort of visualise the goal
in the distance, but the
problem is it's just
not that realistic.
It's like that problem in
quantum mechanics: the act of
measuring something
changes it.
What we really want is a cheap
system that we can use out in
the field that measures
the player without
changing what he does.
One way of doing that is to
take a video of a sporting
performance.
And here we have a greyscale
video of a single tennis shot
during a game.
We've tracked the ball, and we
can look at the brightness of
the pixels surrounding
the ball with time.
And that gives us information
on speed, spin, and angle of
that shot, all with
a single camera.
Now that's great, but it takes a
lot of number crunching, and
we can only get the answer
after the performance.
And as we've seen with our
previous film on diving, we
really want instantaneous
feedback.
And what about bigger and more
complex sports like football?
Like any good engineer, we've
been looking at the tools for
a solution, and we've been
exploring a piece of
technology from a very different
source of game, the
Xbox Kinect.
John, you've been working on
the Kinect sensor for 18
months, and this is the first
time we've had the opportunity
to plug it into an Xbox and
play a game with it.
Tell me how it works.
Obviously, for us to be able
to play this game, what the
Kinect's doing is working out
where we are in three
dimensions.
And the way that it does that
is an infrared projector on
the sensor sends out a speckled
pattern of infrared
dots into the scene, and
compares the image that it
gets from its infrared camera
to an image that's stored on
the device.
And the differences between
those two images tell the
Kinect not only where we are
in the image plane, the
horizontal distances, but where
we are in terms of depth
away and towards the Kinect.
In the lab here we've got a
really expensive bit of kit
that does exactly the same
thing, but costs
1,000 times as much.
So please tell me that we
haven't wasted our money.
Well, the accuracy of the Kinect
looks pretty good.
We might be interested in the
location of a badminton player
on a court, for example.
So we can locate the player
to around about 5 to 10
centimetres of error, which, in
the context of the size of
the badminton court,
is pretty good.
But for finer measurements, the
sort of measurements that
we might take in here with
this system, we might be
interested in measuring joint
angles or the positions of
body segments, we're not getting
the levels of accuracy
that we would see in the lab.
But the benefit of the Kinect
is that it's cheap.
It's essentially a commodity
item, and we can take the
Kinect out and take measurements
in the field, on
a player's badminton court, and
essentially where they're
performing.
How long before we have one of
these out on a football pitch?
It's difficult to say, because
the drivers for this
technology have obviously been
the sort of thing that
normally happens in a living
room, over quite small areas.
So it's difficult to know what
the drivers will be for the
development of the technology
to work over larger areas.
Whoa.
Who's winning?
I have no idea, Steve.
We can take accurate
measurements within the
laboratory, but we're really
constrained by the
environment.
Where we'd really like to be
is out here in the field
taking measurements of the
reality of our athletes.
Now that's a tremendously
challenging thing to do, but
with image processing
techniques, with high
definition cameras, with depth
cameras, combined with mobile
technologies, I think we're
on the verge of
being able to do that.
And for a sports engineer,
that's tremendously exciting.